we humans can easily tell the difference
between happy and sad songs but can this
be captured in an algorithm starting
with guitar chords and 10,000 emotional
words ranked by paid online workers
researchers analyzed which chords were
paired with positive and negative
emotions and lyrics in tens of thousands
of popular songs as expected minor
chords were linked with sad words and
major chords with happy words but the
most positive emotions were conveyed by
seventh chords seventh chords start out
like any other chord with a triad of
notes however sevens add an extra note
on top that changes the sound there are
both major and minor sevenths depending
on the pitch of that extra note and both
are prevalent in heavier songs if you
tell this result to a musician chances
are there may be some head scratching
there's irony in songs pairings of
emotions and sounds that mesh or jar
depending on the intentions of the
creator also sevens are very much the
domain of jazz they add extra complexity
color and texture to many songs that
don't have words but these pairings did
happen in these data this set of songs
there are more sevenths and expected
paired with happy lyrics with this new
take on musical happiness in mind we'll
play ourselves out with a very happy
tune according to this study
[Music]
you
[Music]